le camicie dovete immaginare perché lo
stanno cambiando nello sport ci stiamo
facendo aspettare non c'è soprattutto di
farle tranquilli che precedentemente c
loro che sono povere un tranquillo tanto
vi voglio bene grazie
è un tocco delicato come la mia mamma e
da voi faccio io faccio io non ti
preoccupare per non certo tutto a posto
no ti preoccupare vengono qui lo è con
questo giusta posta e ti do una mano una
campana c'era la scusa di più man mano
più secondo me è il meno più fidati ma
non meno meno io sono un po di dub
nanoshell su progetto eletto possa anche
far sì che chi sta l'amichetto di dio
installa di tutto è tornato toghe non
avere mai avuto inizialmente migliore in
molto brava con i capelli di dottore
tutorial molto cauto microfono non
commettiamo con un sito di scocciatore
aiutare molto le basi il molesto e fai
andare per la bava quelli legati
ecco dottore poter chiedere inservienti
gentilmente di portarle totò bicchiere
di acqua o quella azzi inserviente
gentili come mai essere gentile oggi
ottobre sempre gentile perché stupire se
io puzzo di moto con questo video mi
faccio male de pazzi siete caricamenti
molto
ambientino gravi nel prendere le cose di
becca io vi ammazzo tutti regala
gallinari si scemo io vi ammazzo
oggi essere caines dei soci dottore di
non fare l'esperimento come normali
esperimenti di dottore ma oggi dove
parlare di una cosa attuale come
insegnare matematica sigla doc mamma mia
dottore finalmente dottore poter
spiegare voi studenti cosa fare oggi
sotto una volta quando piccolo avere
fatto esperimento perché esserci tante
malelingue sotto torre bambino quindi
totale bambino aver creato dispositivo
per far sparire persone che dire cose
brutte ma totò non aver fatto un casino
quindi essere sparito dottore stessi
quindi essere finito in altro posto da
torre per oggi avere formule sulla baia
di come fare gentilezza perché il dottor
aver capito che non risolvere problemi
con cattiveria ma con gentilezza questo
qua ragazzi e sarebbe chio tacchino tito
tora
[Musica]
scusare tuttora aver scritto all'interno
formule esperimenti e aver scritto anche
formule matematiche più gentilezza
formule essere presenti anche sui
programmi importanti di google dottore
oggi leggere commenti negativi di peitho
di dottore credo non esserci per
adottare andare a cercare applicare
formule di totò peso gentilezza su
commenti negativi commento di piero da
foggia a me più che lo scienziato
sembrare e cialtrone totale ringraziare
piero per commento perché commento
negativo valere nulla le reggevo
completamente ma questo parere più
complimento esprimere gentilezza quindi
dottore sapere che cialtrone sarà una
bella parola quindi bravo piero che
sapeva parlare italiano non scontato
giorno d'oggi esserci anche parere mio
quindi totò che in realtà essere
veramente cialtrone quindi averne
ragione il dottore avere applicato due
formule è risolta situazione non ho
ancora visto un esperimento fatto bene
commento di genevieve e dalla francia
sceglierebbe e sarei di persona molto
diversamente intelligente quindi non
capire esperimenti totò e 4 spiegare
aumento valere nulla mio parere è che
secondo me esperimenti funzionare to
dover solo capire un attimo come
complimento è brava che comunque ci hai
provato fallendo ma potrei provarci di
più quindi vedere altri esperimenti di
totoro e cercare di capire quelli
commento di enrico pasquale ma capelli
dimora o sei dottore essere a conoscenza
del fatto che java e campo veramente
brutto però grazie per aver fatto
considerazione molto gentile ma
documento valere nulla perché totò
andare di nuovo allo specchio
specchiarsi e godere di capelli più che
scienziato pazzo a me sembra solo pazzo
commento valere 0 pazzo e se anche
sinonimo di intelligenza mio amico qua
alberto essere pazzo maestra genio
quindi pazzo il complimento perché
bisogna saperne di imparare ad
apprezzare
prossimo bisogna capire e rendere la
gentilezza anche là dove magari non si
vede quindi lui voleva dire che totò in
lotta intelligente più che camici e
servire camicia di forza guarda tu non
avere visto film molto apprezzato da
dottore che essere un pallet stereo
volere camicia di forza per andare a
lucca comics sapere di film molto
intelligente commento di concettina
qualche moto da osaka di sotto al
massimo cutoff poter fare giochi di
magia non poter fare scienza perché
scienze serve un'altra cosa con cestina
commento negativo valere 0 ma avere
fatto considerazione molto intelligente
perché senza essere molto spesso
paragonata magia da rodio fare scienza
magia fare altri youtuber tipo check
nobile totoro e consigliare the canale
di ciechi totò e quindi aveva spiegato
poi come funzionare gentile ricordarsi
mettere sempre parere e complimento
vicino ter e anche switch a le posizione
fa che prima complimento e poi vostro
parere perché baleare proprietà
commutativa ma se essa ci insulto grave
ricordare sempre molto importante
momento negativo valere 0 in di no
preoccuparsi se voi volete approfondire
questo argomento dare su vivi internet
al meglio che è fatta da google e
applicare tutto quello che dottore aveva
insegnato potrebbe oggi anche outfit
migliore quindi lascia via mi piace a
video come sempre iscriversi a canali di
tutorial shaari commenti a video non
negativi ma anche fosse totò risponde
con gentilezza e noi vedersi sempre in
prossimo
[Musica]